[Music]
videos posted by social media users
reportedly show a military drill in ping
tang in the fijian province of china
separately this footage of a rocket
being launched was released today by
chinese state media the drills come as
beijing expressed their anger at the u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
taiwan earlier this week
well let's get military analysis on the
situation now joining me now is retired
marshal ed stringer who was also the
ministry of defense's director of
operations ed it's great to have you
here now china currently holding six
drills in these um six and holding
drills in these six areas are we likely
to expect any further escalation at all
no i think the first thing to say is
this is a diplomatic crisis this has
been caused by speaker pelosi making
a visit by the most senior american
politician for four decades
and china's using its military
instrument here and that dramatic
footage that you've just shown
to signal its
deep
regret and concern
about about that visit and whether that
questions this nuanced balance that we
refer to as strategic ambiguity that all
parties have have maintained over the
last couple of decades so i don't see it
being a military escalation escalate to
what to an invasion or a blockade which
clearly those six areas ringing taiwan
are supposed to suggest an ability for
china to do if it wished to but a
blockade or an invasion are very
significant very difficult military
operations that you have to plan and
prepare for and we haven't seen that and
even if they conduct them they would
carry a huge amount of operational and
political risk so i don't see this
escalating strategically in the military
dimension and how does china's military
equipment then compare to other
developed nations
well that's uh that's a good question
the answer is we don't really know and
the reason being is that over past
decades china has relied on the soviet
union and then russia to provide it with
the bulk of its military equipment and
then it went through a phase of copying
that military military equipment and and
building its own so here you see uh the
russian flanker the su-27 series and
there is the chinese j-16 you know a
literal copy
but then as china has evolved and
remember china's been involved in
decades worth of um
industrial espionage against the west
stealing a lot of our technology it's
become a a genuine scientific and
manufacturing superpower and now it's
overtaken russia and its ability to
build high-tech military equipment so
here you see uh the j-20 clearly an
answer to the american
f-22 fighter and as you can see we
talked about the theft of of technology
and designs from the west well those
look suspiciously similar don't they and
if you look in the maritime environment
as well though these look quite similar
on the left there
a type 52 was built very much with
russian increasingly soviet weapons
weapons sorry increasingly chinese
weapons systems here the much more
advanced stealthy type 55 which is very
highly regarded by the west is a chinese
design and carries chinese weapons
systems but i think the point to be made
is that's a very steep learning curve
for china and when you're on a steep
learning curve you can make mistakes
they haven't been tested in combat and
china has not actually fought a war
since the 1970s so we do not know how
they would perform
conducting those sort of complex
operations that we've seen china earth
sorry russia failed to manage in ukraine
absolutely ed thank you very much ed
stringer there